all right next question is from
baruch um addressing this to dr trexler
he notes that greg can chime in as well
but looking at the topic of the question
i am not going to chime in as well
so the question is what is your opinion
on
mini cuts during an extended gaming
phase how long should a mini cut be
how aggressive should they be and what
should training be like
in a mini cut yeah it's a good question
um now i've never been particularly fond
of many cuts but that doesn't mean
that i don't think they're okay so
what i mean by that is there are some
reasons to do mini cuts but i i've never
been
of the opinion that you should like plan
out a weight gaining phase and be like
okay i'm gonna you know bulk for 12
weeks and then have a planned mini cut
for four
because i'd say well why don't why don't
you just take a lower
like a slower rate of weight gain for
those 16 weeks instead of you know
taking
some very ambitious steps forward and
then taking time to take steps backward
if the goal here is to put on some lean
tissue i think we should spend that time
in a surplus so uh
there there are reasons though why
during a weight gaining phase you might
take
you know take a a minute to reassess and
say hey it's time for a mini cut
so you know if you get to a point when
when you're gaining weight and you
become unhappy with how you look
and you're like you know what i'd i'd
feel a lot better if i continued this
weight gain phase but from a leaner spot
which is a totally uh justifiable
perspective to have uh or you could be
unhappy with how you feel
you know you might you might like have
one of those days where you like walk up
a staircase and you're like
um you know that that that was too hard
it shouldn't be that hard
and then you might say yeah i kind of
want to trim up a little bit and
and then reassess the uh uh or kind of
reinitiate the muscle gain phase
um you know you might be unhappy with
some health markers you might go to the
doctor and be like oh those numbers
aren't great
or you might find that you know based on
the type of performance you value that
your weight gain has maybe
had an unfavorable effect on your
performance and you you want to
alleviate that so there are reasons to
do it but but i i also
i'm not a huge fan of the idea that it
should be uh
a pre-planned scheduled in part of the
weight gain process i i don't think that
makes a lot of sense to me
um now let's say you get to that point
you say for
for one of those reasons or for some
reason i didn't think of it's time for a
mini cut
honestly i would treat it uh basically
exactly like
a regular normal cut so i would uh
focus in on what i would deem to be an
appropriate rate of
of weight loss generally speaking that's
going to be somewhere between
0.5 to 1 of body weight
per week and part of the question was
you know how long should the mini cup be
i'd say
work backwards start with what's my
intended rate of weight loss
get on that rate of weight loss and then
however many weeks it takes that's how
many weeks you do
you know you focus on maintaining the
rate of weight loss that seems
appropriate
and when you're there when you're at the
finish line you'll know it
and that's how long it should take um
now when you're on a mini cut i really
don't think that you should have to
adapt your training too much
you might have a natural
urge to kind of dive in and kind of
overdo it with cardio
i think that would be inadvisable
the whole premise of a mini cut would
suggest this really doesn't have to be
an extreme measure
you should be at a place where you have
plenty of fat to lose which is why we're
doing the mini cut in the first place
um i mean you know plenty of fat to lose
is a very uh subjective term but
you're not like at the end of a very
long weight loss diet i mean this should
not be a particularly arduous task to do
a mini cut
at the stage in which you're initiating
the cut
so you shouldn't have to make any really
drastic changes you shouldn't have to
overdo it with the cardio
you really won't have to worry you
really shouldn't
have to worry about metabolic metabolic
adaptation much at all
the nature of a mini cut would suggest
that you have some weight to lose
you're not in a rush to do it so you
should be able to take an appropriate
rate of weight loss in an appropriate
timeline
and so you shouldn't you shouldn't be
pushing into like super low body fat
levels or losing
enormous amounts of weight so metabolic
adaptation really shouldn't be a
critical
uh factor here aside from just some
people need to drop their initial
calories just a little lower than others
if you are going to adapt something in
your training
we had a really nice talk with the other
eric eric helms
about this on the podcast
speaking when you're cutting and you
need to adapt your training um
the easiest things to cut the most
advisable things to cut would be
some of that just annoying accessory
volume that deep down in your heart you
know it's not
it's not really bringing that much to
the table it's just uh
giving you more to recover from and kind
of stealing more minutes of your time at
the gym
so dropping uh some annoying accessory
volume
and i would say to take that a step
further
just dropping extraneous sets from that
volume
so if the option is to trim down the
number of sets on two exercises
or to drop one entirely and leave the
sets alone on the other
i would argue there might be a slight
advantage to just trimming the sets for
each
because i think what you see and greg
you know a lot more about this than i do
just based on your your research
interests but you know
going from one sets to three sets tends
to be a positive thing but eventually
there's diminishing returns where it's
like
you could probably trim back on sets a
little bit and still have a really nice
workout keeping your total number of
exercises
in there um but i mean really
there shouldn't be any huge dramatic
changes because the nature of many cuts
is such that this is not a huge dramatic
thing
you basically you've got to you've
gotten to a point you've arrived at a
point in your weight gain phase where
you say
ah we've kind of gone a little overboard
and you know basically you you find
yourself in a spot where you do wish to
continue
uh gaining lean mass but you know in
some cases we expect that there's going
to be
some residual fat gain along with our
gain of lean mass whenever we do a
weight gain phase
and if you get to a point where you're
like okay this is definitely as
as fat as i would like to become at any
point
but i still have lean mass to gain
that's kind of a final reason where it
would make sense
to do a mini cut and say i know that
during the rest of this
quest to gain lean mass i'm gonna have
some fat mass
gained with it um but at the current
rate at my current ratio of fat mass to
lean mass
that's going to put me at a total amount
of fat mass that i'm really just
uncomfortable with
so that that's another scenario where it
makes sense to kind of recalibrate
that balance of lean mass to fat mass
get a little bit leaner
so that you're like okay now when i
project the rest of this weight gain
phase i i have a decent idea of how much
fat
and lean mass i'll gain the proportion
there
and now i feel like i'll be in a much
better spot when i finish
this weight gain phase so um
just to tie that all up and put it all
in a
concise conclusion it should not really
take a lot of drastic action it should
be
treated basically like you're going to
begin a normal cut
you just end it way earlier you know the
the end point is not the same
we're not trying to get shredded with it
we're trying to just get to a more
manageable
level of body fat so you basically in my
opinion treat it like a normal cut you
should not have to worry about any
dramatic changes in training
dramatic changes in diet uh certainly
metabolic adaptation should not be at
the forefront of your mind for that type
of a cut
and then once you get to a body fat that
you feel a lot better about
now it's time to gain some weight again